foreign
[Music]
10 years ago we created the robots to
now do the tasks Americans once did
Thomas Newton was sentenced to 28 beers
after he had an illegal robot double of
himself you hear that robot
this new girl is different level I'm
glad you've met a nice young lady I need
you completely focused on getting a
horizontal for me put yourself a deep
program now see you too
this Charles guy really wants to bang me
so he'll have to take over tomorrow too
that's the lane just don't want the
night to end I feel the same time
pick up your phone I've never done this
before
also has a robot double you were dating
a robot all along you two and I are
running away together don't try to stop
us goodbye Elaine goodbye let's just
talk about this
don't do it
childish
this is terrible they've completely
stolen our lives I'm gonna have to get a
real job we hunt them down and we kill
them um two cappuccinos thank you you
guys don't understand they're not going
to be obedient anymore
they're humanizing they're learning to
feel you want to get married immediately
let's go away to stop our weddings
enjoy ride is over
hey I get to shoot me sorry I couldn't
resist we'll find that I'm shooting you
that's not fair
oh my God oh my God I shouldn't turn
again
it's deep program now she's ferals
[Music]